25 mil metros cuadrados de tela 3 mil
metros de cuerda roja son los materiales
que se han usado para esta obra póstuma
del artista búlgaro christo él ha
empaquetado el arco de triunfo este
monumento francés la realizó la obra su
sobrino y era un proyecto que él tenía
desde
1961 cuando llegó apenas a francia junto
a su esposa jean claude con la que
trabajaba codo a codo ellos vivían muy
cerca de aquí y desde su ventana veían
este monumento recordemos que no es la
primera obra que él empaqueta en francia
en 1985 hizo lo mismo con el pont neuf
otro símbolo de la ciudad luz este
proyecto ha costado mucho dinero 10
millones de euros pero se han encargado
de decir los colaboradores del sobrino
de cristo que es un dinero que solamente
viene de aportes privados y de la venta
de los croquis de esta misma obra del
artista fallecido el año pasado